it goes without saying that the
beginning of the 21st century may be
called an age of amazing achievements in
science and technology
the launch of the ingenuity rotorcraft
on mars is one of the most recent
groundbreaking events
by now the helicopter has completed
several test flights
and now let's look at each of them more
closely
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
the first flight took place on the 19th
of april 2021
that is when ingenuity rose as high as 3
meters above the planet's surface
and hovered there for almost 40 seconds
the helicopter also took the first black
and white image using its navigation
camera
[Music]
the next flight took place on the 22nd
of april
as it was completing its task ingenuity
rose as high up as 4.9 meters this time
and stayed up there for 51 seconds
in that short time the chopper took its
first color images
and here is what they look like
in these images wheel tracks left by the
perseverance mars rover can be seen
[Music]
by putting together the acquired images
scientists at nasa created a short film
demonstrating ingenuities hovering above
the surface
the next objective to reach was the
third test flight
which was successfully completed on the
25th of april
this time ingenuity rose 5.2 metres high
and then it flew around 50 meters
parallel to the martian surface
before safely returning to the starting
point
this is what it looked like from the
position of perseverance
the rover managed to take pictures and
record a video of the flight from its
vantage point
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and that's what the third flight looked
like from ingenuity's camera
[Music]
interestingly ingenuity developed a
record speed of 2 meters per second in
the course of the flight
with all these indicators nasa was able
to officially announce that the
helicopter had successfully dealt
with all the planned tasks however nasa
decided not to stop there
and carry on with test flights with the
next one taking place on the 30th of
april
in the course of this flight ingenuity
negotiated a staggering 226 meters
within 117 seconds
moving parallel to the surface thus
beating its record and performing twice
as well this time
this achievement was captured by
perseverance as cameras too
[Music]
naturally all these encouraging
achievements prompted the mission
managers to set new objectives for
ingenuity
right now the helicopter is about to
test functions that might be beneficial
for future investigations of mars
the new phase will start after the
helicopter has completed its sixth test
flight
and since ingenuity is still in mint
condition nasa intends to continue using
it to assist the perseverance rover in
its explorations
after its sixth test flight the
helicopter will have about two weeks to
prepare for a new set of operations
demonstrations
focusing on technology tests in all of
its previous flights
this time ingenuity will move on to
demonstrating its functions
for example apart from one-way flights
ingenuity will experiment with precision
maneuvering which will enable it to
cover larger areas of observation
besides at the next phase attempts will
be made to give it more autonomy
so that it relies on assistance of the
perseverance rover team as little as
possible
this means that perseverance will be
able to get on with its chief task
collecting samples of martian rocks and
sediments
as for ingenuity it has planned to be
aiding the rover in coordinating its
movements
to that end the helicopter will execute
short flights
accompanying the rover this strategy
will allow it to collect
aerial imagery of the rover's targets as
well as to promptly work out the rover's
potential routes to waypoints on the fly
interestingly these reconnaissance
flights haven't been initially planned
for ingenuity
this aerial scouting is a kind of bonus
that the mars rover team will benefit
from and will be able to reach their
science goals more efficiently
as for the frequency of the helicopters
flights they will be considerably less
numerous
at this next phase with one test flight
every several days in late april
ingenuity will now set out once
every two or three weeks the flights
themselves are going to be planned in a
way that they will not interfere with
perseverance as science operations
thus the mission team is currently
planning to assess the effectiveness of
such like flying aircraft and mars
a new portion of data beamed back by
ingenuity
will provide new insights into what the
next generation of mini helicopters on
mars should be like
the test flights meanwhile are scheduled
until around the end of august
if all of them are completed
successfully nasa will be able to draw
conclusions from the ingenuity mission
and proceed to develop new aircraft of
this kind
we in our turn will keep you posted on
the missions updates
if you'd like us to carry on bringing
you the latest news feel free to let us
know in the comments
or just hit the like button by way of
saying yes and
let's keep in touch
you